to the relief of everyone the Buffalo
Bill's safety is now breathing on his
own talking and even join his teammates
on a video conference call Friday
Hamlin went into cardiac arrest after
making a tackle during Monday night's
game against the Bengals the NFL took
the extraordinary step to postpone and
then cancel the game while Hamlin's
condition is improving the incident
reminds us of how fragile Our Lives can
be
we are used to seeing injuries in sports
sometimes bad ones on football fields
but this week was different
a man's heart stopped
he would have died if not for immediates
and heroic medical attention
as teammates stood by in anguish
Millions watched stunned on television
there were prayers but not much
information
we have more now lately good things we
know Demar Hamlin is on the road to
recovery
we know the small GoFundMe he started to
buy toys for kids with an initial goal
of twenty five hundred dollars has now
raised more than 8 million
we know athletes play sports because
they love it despite the risks
we love to watch them because we love it
despite the disappointments
the hope of glory always outweighs the
more likely pain of defeat
but injuries are one thing
mortality is another
there was a stark reminder of that
Monday night
and that brings perspective
the entertainment we watch is not free
it gives
but also takes
hopefully not ever
more than we can handle
the mood shift that happened on Thursday
when they announced that he it appeared
he was neurologically intact was amazing
yeah and it was just like yes you know I
thought everybody was just waiting for
that to happen and the news has only
gotten better and better now so I can't
wait to see what it's going to be like
um on on tomorrow yeah I immediately
thought of you Jeff because I know what
a fan of the bills you are we all do
um but it reached out to everybody and
hit us like a ton of bricks well I think
that's what you saw with the charity
people just wanted to do something
anything yeah yeah it was how do you you
couldn't process what had happened we as
you point out we see so many
catastrophic injuries in sports but you
always see the thumbs up at the end you
see the Mike Utley thumbs up yes yes you
didn't see that this time I think even
before hearing about the video
conference when you heard heard the
doctors talk the day before and say that
he wanted to know if they had won the
game that was that first moment of
there's something there yes that it may
be okay we do we do uh love yeah for
three yeah or watch for the threes
tomorrow yeah